Ask and it shall be given you seek and
you shall find knock and it shall be
opened unto you for everyone that asks,
receives and he that seeketh findeth and
to him that knocks it shall be opened.
That sounded pretty optimistic again,
but,
but again,
I think it's a description of the
structure of existential reality and and
by,
by which I mean
when I'm in my clinical practice and I
observe and this is also the case with
my students,
is let's say people's lives aren't what
they would like them to be.
And so then you ask why?
Well,
forget about tragedy and catastrophe
because that's self evident and we're
not going to discuss that.
Although the degree to which you bring
about your own tragedy is always
indeterminant.
But I would never say that every
terrible thing that is visited on a
person is something they deserved.
I think that that's a very dangerous
presupposition,
especially because everyone gets sick
and everyone dies,
but one of the main reasons that people
don't get what they want is because they
don't actually figure out what it is and
the probability that you're going to
get.
What would be good for you,
let's say,
which would even be better than what you
want,
right?
Because you know,
you might be wrong about what you want
easily,
but maybe you could get.
What would really be good for you?
Well,
why don't you.
because you don't try.
You don't think,
okay,
here's what I would like if I could have
it and I don't mean I don't mean in a
way that you manipulate the world to
force it to deliver you good for status
or something like that.
That isn't what I mean.
I mean something like imagine that you
were taking care of yourself like you
were someone you actually cared for and
then you thought,
okay,
I am caring for this person.
I would like things to go as well for
them as possible.
What would their life have to be like in
order for that to be the case where
people don't do that?
They don't sit down and think,
all right,
do you know?
Let's,
let's figure it out.
You're,
you've got a life.
It's hard.
Obviously.
It's like three years from now you can
have what you need.
You got to be careful about it.
You can't have everything you can have,
what would be good for you,
but you have to figure out what it is
and then you have to aim at it.
Well,
my experience with people is been as if
they figure out what it is that would be
good for them and then they aim at it.
Then they get it and it's strange
because they don't ness.
It's a strange thing.
It's not quite that simple because you
know,
you may formulate an idea about what
would be good for you and then you take
10 steps towards that and you find out
that your formulation was a bit off and
so you have to reformulate your goal.
So you're kind of going like this as you
move towards the goal.
But a huge part of the reason that
people fail is because they don't ever
set up the criteria for success.
And so since success is a very narrow
line and very unlikely,
the probability that you're going to
stumble it randomly is zero.
And so if there's a proposition here in
the proposition is if you actually want
something,
you can have it now,
the question then would be,
well,
what do you mean by actually want?
And the answer is that you reorient your
life in every possible way to make the
probability that that will occur as
certain as possible.
And that's a sacrificial idea,
right?
It's like you don't get everything,
obviously you obviously,
but maybe you can have what you need and
maybe all you have to do to get it is
ask,
but asking isn't a whim or,
or today's wish.
It's like you have to be deadly serious
about it.
You have to think,
okay,
I'm taking stock of myself and if I was
going to live properly in the world and
I was going to set myself up such that
being would justify itself in my
estimation.
And I don't mean as a harsh judge
exactly what is it that I would aim at?
Well,
one of the things I've found is that in
test of this theory,
let's say you could try this.
This is a form of prayer knocking.
Sit on your bed one day and ask
yourself,
what's what remarkably stupid things am
I doing on a regular basis to absolutely
screw up my life,
and if you actually asked that question,
but you have to want to know the answer,
right,
because that's actually what asking the
question means.
It doesn't mean just mouthing the words.
It means you have to decide that you
want to know.
You'll figure that out so fast.
It'll make your hair curl,
you'll you.
It's as if young thought about this,
he saw it.
He thought that people had two poles of
consciousness in one was the individual
consciousness that we each identify
within.
The other was something he called the
self and the self is the.
You might think about it as the divine
within.
That's close enough approximation.
It's the universal part of your
consciousness.
It's your conscience.
That's another way of thinking about it.
Whatever your conscience is,
but it's something that you can consult.
It's like the socratic daymond socrates
said that the thing that made him
different than everyone else in Greece
was that he consulted his demon,
his genius.
He asked himself how it was that he
should conduct himself in the world,
and then he did that,
whatever it was,
he didn't try to force a solution.
You know,
Selfishly,
he asked,
I'm going to manifest myself in the best
possible manner in the world.
I would like to do that.
What would that be?
While you're perfectly capable of
thinking,
God only knows how you're perfectly
capable of immense feats of imagination
and dreams and fantasies,
God only knows how you do all of that.
What would happen if you consulted
yourself about the best possible outcome
for you?
You might get an answer.
Well,
that's what this proposition is.